les nouvelles ambitions du musée de
l'air du bourget le musée veut devenir
une vitrine de l'aéronautique européenne
et attirer davantage de visiteurs mais
pour cela bien sûr il faut de l'argent
le musée aurait besoin de 400 millions
de francs denis faire d'écart constable
pour devenir le premier musée
aéronautique et spatiale d'europe le
musée de l'air et de l'espace du bourget
qui va fêter bientôt son 80e
anniversaire a besoin de subventions on
parle d'une enveloppe de 400 millions de
francs pour assurer son développement et
relancer son activité
nous avons tous les éléments pour avoir
un musée on peut dire vivant adapté aux
désirs des visiteurs de l'an 2000
notre ambition c'est de devenir le grand
musée européen de l'air et de l'espace
l'objectif du musée qui reçoit cent
trente mille visiteurs par an et de
passer à un million dans les cinq ans né
en 1919 il possède deux fabuleuses
collections historiques pas assez mise
en valeur et entend rester la vitrine du
savoir-faire passées et à venir de
l'aéronautique
nous sommes le grand musée de la seine
saint denis et à ce titre là et bien
nous servons un dessein national
européen et nous savons aussi projets de
proximité rappeler à toutes les
populations des villes qui nous
environne que
leurs parents leurs grands parents ont
travaillé au bourget notre situation à
paris nous permet également de faire de
très grands projets nouveaux halls
d'exposition nouvelles réserves
muséographique et mise en valeur de
l'aérogare classés sont les enjeux à
relever dans le cadre du contrat de plan
état région 2000 2006 pour faire du
bourget le grand centre scientifique et
technique de l'aventuré rien et spatial
du troisième millénaire